Miley Cyrus celebrating an international
kissing day with the best throwback of
her and Liam Hemsworth ever she tweeted
out this pic from the set of the last
song quote our first smooch eight years
ago
[Music]
I mean we shouldn't on the beach ever
that was pretty fun
et was with Miley and Liam at the
premiere of that movie in 2010 they
revealed this about each other I always
say she eats a lot of sushi but I think
everyone knows that he's a lot of sushi
too and he actually likes fashion so
it's good that you are not like nothing
and they had this to say about falling
for each other on set nothing is a
little bit of a shock to her to
experience my kind of life I don't know
I we I mean we just I took it to the
beach that was pretty much it go to the
beige chemistry was so much chemistry
with someone and I'm not gonna be a
little out of that about that once you
know people see us on screen together I
mean it I
there's no point denying her you know I
mean I don't like to talk about my
private life but there's been somebody
photos of us together and kissing and
[Music]